that girl just didn't react to that
future technology
no it's yeah i am here get out of here
get out of here stop it someone else
stop it stop teasing us
get out of here don't play your games
with us this time
we're going to take you down see devil
yeah memphisto wouldn't be afraid of the
tva that's how you know
that's how you know let's not waste
another minute settling
strong i love her that's my wife
that's my wife missing long ago there
was a vast multiversal war
countless unique timelines war each
other for supremacy
nearly resulted in what total
destruction bro
everything but then this is important
bringing peace by reorganizing the
multiverse into a single
timeline this lies
this changes the whole game i don't
believe that
what bro bro look is that the first
person to do this
yo what does that mean oh
we actually got a lot of those we got a
whole box of them
jangly ones bruh infinity war
paperweights are you kidding me for real
words creepy
is the trailer it's the trailer hoods
[Music]
why would you do that mother nature
yo yo they got murdered
they're done yeah those are those tv
those are toasted tva members
yo you got played you got played
oh
welcome back to new rock stars loki
episode 1
shattered our glorious purpose of marvel
expertise
with new revelations about moki's god
status
the way timelines and the multiverse
function in the mcu
and a devilish villain triggering us
from some one division days there's a
lot to explain with this new series so
let's all wait a damn damn minute
this is inside marvel new rock stars
loki after show
i'm eric voss my easter egg breakdown of
the episode is coming later today but
here right now after watching the
episode here i am with
mt hey man what's going on actually you
got to see my full government name it's
now empty
minutes because i got married to miss
minutes over the weekend
oh congratulations mt after this episode
i can't blame you
what an amazing series premiere right so
i'm good away mind blown first episode
immediately
empty let's break down what happened
this episode yes let's do it
um so in this loki premiere the god of
bishop escapes a recreated time ice and
avengers end game only to be detained by
the time variants authority marvel's
time cops that's right and as loki gets
processed through this sterile
bureaucratic nightmare
uh it gets explained through this
hilarious cartoon from miss minutes
new doggy very much like mr dna
in jurassic park that loki
by stealing the tesseract created a
violation to the sacred
timeline that's overseen by these
godlike time keepers who
ended some past multiverse war by
weaving together all the timelines into
one
and they say that the avengers time
heist and end game was supposed to
happen
but loki stealing the space stone was
not and that these kinds of variances
must be
pruned like branches to maintain the
sacred timeline
and they do that by using these special
reset canisters
yes i love the branch imagery that's all
around the tva it's really cool
yeah it's like the tree branch imagery
but yes tva agent mobius
aka owen wilson in real life pursues
someone murdering minutemen and stealing
their timeline reset canisters
this killer left a future candy back in
16th century france that mobius is like
why your teeth blue girl yeah
i assume it's based on bazooka uh gum
but um
might actually be explosive as uh
off-screen producer zach joked uh we'll
see
if that happens who knows um now
uh loki it's technically loki variant
label
l1130 from the year 2012
that's right in the middle of the
avengers events after the battle of new
york
uh he now witnesses how his life was
supposed to play out
that includes losing friga in thor the
dark world and connecting with thor
and ragnarok and of course his death in
infinity war that kind of changes his
perspective on his uh
guaranteed ascent to greatness oh yes
for sure
and loki also realizes that the tva has
a ton of
alternate timeline infinity stones that
they use as paperweights apparently
which is the most craziest thing because
we were waiting for the infinity stones
for 10 years and they're just like in
somebody's drawer
basically telling him that his glorious
purpose for power is a joke in the eyes
of the all uh you know authoritative tva
that's right uh and uh mobius since
they're making a deal with justice wren
slayer that's google
to use loki to hunt down this mysterious
killer
who he reveals is an alternate timeline
loki and in the final scene this hooded
figure
lures tva minutemen to an oklahoma oil
field in the year 1858
where the agents are burned alive as his
figure steals another
reset canister damn whoa
like literally this person's not playing
whoever this person is they're not
turning around because they just
murdered all those people in the most
way possible wow and it is this mystery
devil that we're to be starting with but
first right now it is time for our big
latest obsession reveal this is our
latest
latest obsession latest decision number
four loki
out of time i've already ordered 10 of
these just for myself to hoard them
because as you know these shirts are
first come first served
uh so maybe already go to
newrockstarsmerch.com while i'm talking
to get yours
and of course as we do here on inside
marvel buying the latest obsession shirt
will give you the ability to
leave a message on the show with either
a shout out to your friends loved ones
or secret dark elf family
or drop your own crazy theories about
where this show is headed
and it'll show up right here at the
bottom of the screen but wait there's
more
like we previously announced just like
how kevin feige said that loki was going
to be the biggest thing to happen to the
mcu since
end game well the same thing is true
over at epic hero shop they just dropped
the entire loki collection and holy crap
they made all of our dreams come true
we're talking multiple loki shirts
yes including another augmented reality
shirt that will show off
all the different variants in alternate
realities
which is just proof that technology
sufficiently advanced enough
is indistinguishable from magic but
they've also got some other badass loki
prints
cell phone cases i saw an awesome tie
and socks and
nt again i'm gonna need you to keep
together about this but
all kinds of miss minutes are you
kidding me
miss minutes merch my wife i gotta get
on it i need it
in hell let's give you guys a discount
code enter code the real slim
loki and get 10 off your entire order
that's a limited use of the code by the
way so once you've all
worn it out it's gone forever but okay
empty i see you ordering out of the
corner of your eye don't worry i think
you get
a discount anyway as always go to
newrockstarsmerch.com and scoop up all
the amazing one-of-a-kind low-key swag
and enter that code
the real slim loki to get that 10 off
anyway mt what's our first question well
our first
weight of that minute of the day is
waited a minute who was the devil that
that french boy pointed to
was it mephisto short answer no
it is not mephisto
it's yeah it's not mephisto i don't
think this isn't one division
a show in which mephisto tied very
deeply into the comic storyline it was
based on
this is different i mean you could say
that mephisto is technically in the
background of everything
whether or not he actually reveals
himself on screen but no no no
the series director kate herron and
showrunner mike waldron confirmed
entertainment
tonight that it's not mephisto they said
quote it's honestly just a super weird
coincidence
like it's genuinely a reference to loki
the horns
he was cast out of heaven that's what
it's a reference to
because we filmed that a long time
before i think wanna vision must have
been
in post when we filmed that i did see
all the stuff about that online and was
like oh this is gonna be interesting
but no it's more relevant to the themes
of our show and it's not a nod to the
character but then mike walter kept our
hopes alive by saying it would be
interesting if
what pistol ever showed up in the mcu
nope don't do this come on
don't do this why you don't do that to
the fire
um but let's talk about what this is so
our introduction to mobius comes in the
year 1549
in exxon provence france uh mobius
investigates the murder of other
minutemen and that boy who witnessed the
killing was given kablooey gum by this
person not something you would find in
the 16th century france
uh and then when he was asked who did
this the boy points to that stained
glass window showing a red-faced demon
with horns
wearing green robes uh now i gotta say
here as someone who grew up catholic
who has visited his share of catholic
cathedrals in europe it's pretty weird
to see a stained glass art
of satan sitting on a throne like little
nauseas
like if lucifer if if he's ever
shown he doesn't show up in art of
course but he's like you know glaring up
from hell
or he's creeping in on baby jesus or
he's like getting body slammed by the
archangel michael
you know he's not just hanging out um
but
uh then mobius says in english so i
doubt the kid could understand him he
says ah don't worry that devil's afraid
of us
we'll take care of him but yes as the
producers explained this is more about
the parallels to
loki the figure wearing green he's got
horns he's cast out of heaven
as the way uh loki was cast out of
asgard um
yes loki's headgear is famously horned
and we know from trailer footage that
this series will explore
alternate loki variants including a
president loki
who wears this past crown just along
with his you know uh
indoor slippers but we have also
surmised from
every trailer that's come out uh the
figure who attacks the tva
agents in the oil field the one wearing
the hood
uh who has appeared in various flashes
elsewhere in the footage
is probably going to be sophia
dimartino's character who we have
theorized could be everyone from
enchantress to
it's probably going to be based on this
villainy loki variant
lady from the comics um now we don't
know for sure yet but um
lady loki actually comes about in a
pretty different way in the comics it's
after the ragnarok event
when all the asgardian souls are just
floating about looking for new bodies to
be reincarnated into
and a body is made for lady siff
but instead gets snatched by loki's soul
just to kind of screw around with thor
and it results in the character of lady
loki um
now in this show they may justify the
character as a female version from an
alternate timeline especially since
if you look closely at loki's rap sheet
and this came out a couple days ago it
listed his sex as
fluid yes it's canon loki it's canada
i'm all about it i'm all about it too uh
there's a couple other visual clues too
like that white on black
loki title that opens and closes the
episode the o often appears with
curved horns uh and then also we should
point out in that stained glass there is
a crescent moon
and in the trailer footage demartino's
character can be seen sitting on a
planet while a moon
crashes down overhead okay uh so yeah i
think the devil that the french boy
uh saw was whatever evil loki did this
and most likely lady loki
and it's also possible that an even
lokier loki beyond her the lokius loki
a loki or loki the lokist uh it's where
it's
you know people worked on the show were
rick and morty writers it seems like
they're going a similar direction
um that could be the whatever mystery
character richard e
grant is playing because i don't think
i could be wrong about this i just don't
feel like demartino's character is gonna
stay the villain of this show
but rather be revealed as an anti-hero
fighting to thwart an even worse threat
alongside loki yeah yeah i get those
vibes too
because like it definitely feels like
they're setting like we don't know the
full picture yet obviously because
episode one
so like yeah i have that feeling too
sorry
uh but well here's my theory i wanna
hear your theory on this too mt i think
that
whoever that ultimate big bad is uh
beyond lady loki they may have invented
the timekeepers sacred timeline origin
myth as a kind of cover story
like it's all [ __ ] and that by
mushing the multiverse into one sacred
timeline
these timekeepers actually were choosing
winners and losers
at the behest of someone else maybe
he who remains that was the final tba
agent in the comics
who created the time keepers so while
the hooded woman with horn antlers
may be the devil that the french boys
saw i think this show's ultimate devil
is going to be the man behind the
curtain
of the tva itself interesting
yeah i i have this weird feeling that
you know the timekeepers probably aren't
the best people they're probably the
true villains
of this whole thing i don't know if i i
don't know if if he human remains will
actually show up
but i had this weird feeling that it's
just these three [ __ ]
that are just like all right history's
supposed to go this way and nothing else
um but it would be great if we got a
huge remain to keep it like more
faithful to the comics but
yeah it does make sense that somebody um
you know some authoritative figure in
the tva
is is doing some some shady [ __ ] that's
not not good yeah
i am i'm debating do you think we'll
ever see the actual timekeepers in this
show because i'm wondering if these were
just kind of like artificial
constructions
uh kind of like the the wizard of oz
face and they were created as these
all-powerful beings but really it's just
kind of clockwork that's keeping it all
running
and whether it's he who remains or just
someone else high up
uh running the tv some director at a
high ranking level
um kind of created this myth and then
that's why they don't let loki
talk to the timekeeper says there's no
one to talk to that would be
a great twist and hilarious i think
that's a really great possibility
but i honestly think that the t of the
timekeepers are real well
there are more questions we want to talk
about from this episode first one thanks
some friends who helped us make it thank
you to hellofresh for sponsoring this
episode of inside marvel with hello
fresh you get fresh pre-measured
ingredients and mouth-watering seasonal
recipes delivered right to your door
i've really enjoyed the hell of fresh
recipes i've tried the korean inspired
beef bulgogi
meatballs i think that's how you say it
they're really tasty and they're the
first time i've ever made my own
meatball from scratch i learned
something new for sure
hellofresh offers the flexibility you
need to easily customize your order on
the app within minutes
easily change your delivery day food
preferences plant size or skip a week
whenever you need
as someone who likes to cook but isn't
super skilled at it
or have a lot of time to meal plan
hellofresh is a lifesaver
i know that i can get something tasty
and interesting on the plate in less
time than it would take to get takeout
or delivery
enjoy a wide variety of easy delicious
options
for all three meals a day plus every
snack and special treat in between with
a hellofresh market
go to hellofresh.com 12 marvel and use
the code
12 marble for 12 free meals
including free shipping that's
hellofresh.com
12 marvel and use the code 12 marvel
for 12 free meals from america's number
one meal kit 12 model
yup well marble we also want to thank
stamps.com for sponsoring this episode
are you still going to the post office
still paying full price for postage well
thanks to stamps.com
you will never have to do that ever
again mail and ship anytime
anywhere right from your computer you
can send letters ship packages and pay
less
a lot less with discounted rates from
usps ups and more
with stamps.com you get discounts up to
40 off
post office rates and up to 66 off ups
shipping rates
and new rockstars we sometimes have to
ship packages all over the world
off-screen producer zach recently had to
ship packages to new zealand and
singapore
and stamps.com helped him figure out how
much it would cost and saved him a ton
of time waiting in line at the post
office
that's time he used to play more
tabletop board games which he
recently defeated most of new rockstars
staff at
he did beat us uh he makes us call him
off-screen
gamelord zack which he is so stop
wasting time going to the post office
and go to stamps.com instead there's no
risk and with our promo code marvel
you get a special offer that includes a
four week trial plus free postage and a
digital scale
no long-term commitments or contracts
just go to stamps.com click
the microphone at the top of the home
page and type in marvel that's
stamps.com promo codemarvelstamps.com
never go to the post office again
and we want to thank helix sleep for
sponsoring this episode you don't want
to sleep on a mattress designed for
someone else
even if that other person is a variant
of yourself they probably sleep on their
side instead of their back and they like
a super firm mattress because they're
evil
well helix sleep has a quiz that matches
your body type and sleep preferences to
the perfect mattress for you
they have soft medium and firm
mattresses mattresses great for cooling
down if you sleep hot
or even a helix plus mattress for plus
size sleepers
i took the quiz and got matched with the
dusk luxe helix mattress because i
wanted a medium firm mattress with
lumbar support and sleeves cool and i
sleep great on my helix mattress way
better than my evil variant
twin does probably the mattress
yeah that's right
eric with the ck those are the worst oh
my god
um i'm sorry for all eric's with cks you
guys are fine just not as good as eric's
with k's
yeah that's just a rule superior of
course that's right
the mattress ships right to your door
for free you never need to go to a
mattress store again isn't that great
they were awarded the
number one best overall mattress pick of
2020 by gq and wired magazine so you
just go to helixsleep.com
inside marvel take their two-minute
sleep quiz and they'll match you to a
customized mattress that will give you
the best sleep of your life
helix is offering up to two hundred
dollars off all mattress orders and two
free pillows for our audience at
helixsleep.com
inside marvel that's helix sleep.com
inside marvel for up to 200
off and two free pillows our next
question of the day is wait a day a
minute why was loki detained by the tva
if stealing the tesseract
didn't take him into a new reality yeah
so this is something we've talked a bit
about on the channel but
i i realize it is kind of a tough thing
for people to wrap their heads around
um so loki when he took the tesseract
it's the space stone right so it allows
teleportation within a universe to any
other point in space
um but just by doing that loki
skewed himself and the tesseract off of
their historical destined path
so what was supposed to happen is loki
and the tesseract were supposed to
return to asgard
and the tesseract was supposed to go
into odin's vault loki was supposed to
go
into the prison on asgard um but by even
just by jumping over to mongolia as he
does here
um he skews this whole reality with him
onto a branch timeline from the sacred
timeline so uh imagine the sacred
timeline still
bobbing along unchanged the avengers
everything they do in the future
still happened but loki we are now in
the point of view of a variant
on a variant timeline right um so it
doesn't matter that he
doesn't travel through time doesn't
matter that he doesn't jump into a
different dimension or a different
reality
just by taking the infinity stone and
stepping onto
a new path uh he now changes his course
of history
uh and that changes from the sacred
timeline uh meanwhile the avengers
with cap returning all the stones at the
end of end game patched all those
branches up
so the sacred timeline was restored that
way
loki now that he knows his uh future
or what was going to happen he has no
interest in returning to that sacred
timeline
because he knows it ends with him
getting you know so
he wants to kind of stay in this place
of limbo with the tva willing to go
along with mobius
on uh this investigation because he
knows the alternative is to just live
out uh in the sacred timeline that ends
with his failure
no that makes a lot of perfect sense to
me because like you know the tva
is out here and the timekeepers or
rather um they're dictating
what the proper flow of time is they're
basically dictating fate
and i think that this is what might be
happening with loki where he's just like
i don't like the time keepers they're
like they say that my fate is to be this
evil
jerk so like i'm gonna just do away with
fate in general like i'm done with
things
right um so yeah i do like that theory
because it makes sense it just makes
sense
yeah i yeah i think what uh
people have to remember is like i know
endgame didn't do a very good job
explaining
the timeline logic of that movie they
kept having to reshoot new scenes to
make it more clear
um but uh and also they confused it by
having
uh cap as an old man show up at the end
you know and they're right
directors disagreed there what that
actually meant
uh but basically the way the mcu
timeline works now
is it's a mini world's theory it's it
branches off in alternate timelines that
coexist
uh you gotta brush up on your irwin
schrodinger
uh we'll maybe focus on that in some uh
videos coming up
but uh next question i want to ask you
empties wait a damn minute
what was this uh cartoon talking about
uh
multiversal war
and this whole history this new history
of the timekeepers
merging all these different multiverses
into one
sacred timeline and do you think by the
end of the show empty that this sacred
timeline will inevitably
unravel oh 100 like the sacred timeline
is screwed like there's no way it would
be kind of boring at the same
time if the sacred timeline was fine by
the end of all this
because like why because like they
specifically say in the uh the cartoon
the terms multiverse and madness
specifically they use the term
right yeah they did but then the
all-knowing timekeepers emerged
bringing peace by reorganizing the
multiverse into a single timeline
stepping off your path created a nexus
event
which left unchecked could branch off
into madness
which is very interesting um because of
the the movie coming out
so yeah this is gonna end with the
unraveling of the sacred timeline i hope
and things are about to get bananas um
yeah and i
really hope that this multiversal war
that they're talking about is
a reference to a secret wars because
like that's basically
what what i feel is gonna happen i feel
like we're gonna get this multiversal
war again once the timeline
the sacred timeline goes crazy and like
if you look at the
the uh the image you see like the
timelines intersecting with each other
and so i think those are what they order
called the incursions in the marvel
comics where
um to uh time oh i guess in this case
timelines or two realities i should say
in the marvel comics sense come together
and that that's the juncture point where
uh
things go down um so yeah i think
that's that multiversal war that's
happening where like
these intersections are happening
incursions are happening and two
timelines are fighting with each other
so um i love that so i think that that's
what
kevin feige and friends are setting up
here with this multiverse award the
secret wars
well i'm gonna i'm gonna do you one
crazier empty
let's do it i am wondering if the
implication
of this mythology is that time is kind
of a flat circle in the mcu
that we are part of a universal cycle
and what we are now in is kind of a
peace time of the universal cycle
where things are kind of in one timeline
but really
everything that we're seeing in the mcu
has happened before
including uh a multiverse of madness
where different variants of avengers and
guardians of the galaxy
in the fantastic four in mutants and all
of them have been in crazy different
wars with each other
and then each time the timekeepers reset
it and they reset the clock
and it's kind of like in the matrix
right and what we saw as neo was the
sixth iteration of the chosen one right
and each time the machines
like clockwork just kind of reset it and
we go through it again
and what may happen this time is that
wanda maximoff may represent an anomaly
within that clockwork
or loki could be that the anomaly within
that clockwork who just breaks it in
just the right way
to stop this cycle uh who breaks the
wheel
uh to use the game of thrones uh term
there
i'm sorry about that by the way uh who
truly breaks the wheel
uh and sets it on this permanent
multiverse of madness
that can never possibly be reset and
loki truly burns it to the ground
dude i know i always say i dig it but i
dig it man
i'm digging digging a grave baby of my
theories
and just burying myself flowers springs
and then
dies hey man hey we we just theorizing
out here we marvel scientists me and you
we got a hypothesis i bought this off
and wrong and then we try it again
uh but what's our next uh question
empty all right our next question of the
day is
wait a damn minute how did the tva get
the alternate timeline infinity stones
that they're just using
paperweights i know i know is that so
great so one thing i was kind of missing
from this explanation mt is that
according to the ancient one
only the displacement of infinity stones
causes branches to the sacred timeline
this animated cartoon didn't you know
one of the animator carters
uh they didn't uh include that specific
detail of infinity stones being the
ticket to rye to get on a on a new
timeline
um but i'm wondering if the reason why
they have drawers full of these things
is that
every detainee every variant they
capture
got there because they stole an infinity
stone or they happened to get it by
accident or something like that and then
they just took it on whatever its
alternate
path was or they used it the way loki
used it to teleport away
they used the time stone to unwind
something they uh used the power stone
to blow something up
you know and that this josh fadim played
a character who's like the son of a kid
on goldman sachs maybe he used
one of these infinite stones to like
make a lot of money or something like
that
maybe that scroll uh was like uh
you know somewhere on xandar and then
the orb rolled up to his feet and he
picked it up and he's like cool
and then he used it to blow up a bunch
of cree and so they kidnapped that
scroll
like you know like all of these people
just have these infinity stones once
they get detained they
they get brought into the tva they
confiscate the infinity stone it's
powerless
because there are so many of them and
with each new one that they uh collect
it it dilutes the power even further of
each one
i think that the reason that first of
all i like that um
second of all i think that the reason
why the infinity stones don't work is
because they're in the null time zone
and that the infinity stones are tied to
their specific
universes and like if they're not inside
the universe then they're just rocks
i think that this is probably the result
of you know people like you said
taking the infinity stones and trying to
use it um that's not
in a way that's not according to that
initial thanos avengers plan that the
timekeepers apparently wanted i don't
know why they wanted it but
sure let's just have half of the
universe die and then
come back um but yeah i think that there
are people that have these high
aspirations these other thanos's
that collect the infinity stones they're
stopped and they brought in and then
they just drop the rocks off
um yeah but do you think it's um like
because uh the ancient one also said
something like the infinity stones
create what you perceive as the flow of
time
right and so she kind of created this
idea that the stones are necessary
in a timeline uh in order to keep it
flowing
uh and the russos have even said well
that's why we said thanos
atomized the stones the stones were not
completely destroyed they were just
atomized so they exist in some form
just kind of dispersed you know their
energy is still there that cosmic energy
is still pumping forward but the uh i
wonder if like
when they clipped off these timelines
they were able to clip it in a way that
kind of
reset six stones within the timeline
within the sacred timeline
leaving this one as kind of a discarded
variant stone
that is because the variant in the no
time zone it just kind of like
it turns off it like it loses all of its
power bro if someone broke into the tva
and stole all the stones that would be a
terrible thing
oh what if that happens like what if
like so
well you you remember there was that
clip
uh where eugene corganero's character
was like well they use them as paper
weights
most of them use them as paper weights
which you know my brain was like well
which [ __ ] used it for something
else and i'm thinking like
was kang or one of these guys an
employee of the tva
who took one of these infinity stones
took the time stone like the first time
stone theft
back before they collected a whole bunch
of them and then went off at his own
skewed timeline
and screwed up a bunch of stuff yo
anything's possible now that you have
like a an office full of green rocks
literally anything's possible oh that's
the one that loki picked up too he
picked
up the green time stone he's like ooh
bro that dude still has it
he's there's no way he didn't he still
has it in his pocket that's gonna come
in just in case that's a
tool though that's going to come in
handy later remember that guys
but yeah no i'm really looking for i
hope they explain where all these
alternate infinity stones come from
because i need to know
um uh we have a couple more questions we
want to answer one more person who
helped us make this episode thank you to
our friends at blue chew for
the ultimate infinity stone of all the
blue you know
you know it you know uh blue chew has a
unique online service that delivers the
same active ingredients as viagra and
cialis but in chewable format at a
fraction of the cost
bluetooth is an online prescription
service so no doctor's office or
pharmacy trips
it ships right to your door in a
discrete package and you sign up at
bluechew.com consult with one of their
licensed medical providers and once
you're approved you receive a
prescription within days
their licensed medical providers work
with you to find the right ingredient in
strength and blue chew
is chewable just like it says in the
name which is great news for folks that
don't like swallowing pills
so if you could benefit from some extra
confidence where it counts blue chew can
help and we've got a special deal for
our listeners to drive bluetooth free
when you use our promo code
inside marvel at checkout just pay the
five dollars in shipping that's
bluetooth.com promo code inside marvel
to receive your first month for free
visit bluetooth.com for more details and
important safety information and we
thank bluetooth for sponsoring the
episode
okay uh empty wait a damn minute
what did moebius mean by saying
nightmares
are quote another department and that he
wanted to help loki
burn it down yo i was flipping out my
dude i was like wait a minute
what what you know we can't just gloss
over that we need to go back to what you
just said
rewind yeah get the time twister i'd
love to become time twisters by the way
yeah like a little nod to them they're
legit time twisters it's so cute that's
right
that's right that's right yeah so what
what is the nightmare department what do
you think that is
honestly i mean it's the first guess
that i'm sure that everyone's gonna take
from this is nightmare
the doctor stranger oh yeah like that's
pretty much uh i i would say a very
clear you know
pointing to the existence of nightmare
in the mcu which
i hope that they get into and doctor
strange and multiverse of badness i mean
with mike waldron being the the writer
of the head writer of the series and
you know the writer of episode one you
know and him being the writer of
doctor strange the multiverse of madness
that would be a nice little easter egg
or seed right to put in there for the to
be fulfilled in dr strange too
but that's fingers crossed we're not
saying that nightmare is necessarily
coming
but come on we're saying that's a huge
hint towards the existence of nightmare
at the very least
yeah i love that they would have an
entire department to have to handle it
because i don't think uh like i
nightmare is a cosmic entity that exists
uh just in the dream dimension right and
he's kind of that he feeds off of
negative emotions and he
is kind of implied to be the source of
people's nightmares you know
um it's all him feeding off of you and
feeding off of your energy um
but uh so the i don't know why the tva
would be uh responsible for like
investigating people's nightmares
because they're they seem more focused
on the you know the sacred timeline
so unless it's like uh somehow a
nightmare is
uh is affecting the timeline or that
people's
nightmares come from past forgotten
memories of things that have been
rhett cannoned you know like uh like
when
every time something gets wrecked cannon
there's a trace memory that exists in
people's subconscious
that uh you know becomes someone's
nightmare at night someone's stress
stream that you're just remembering
pieces of a forgotten timeline uh and
that's why they have this nightmare
department is because they're like
we have to like it's like their damage
control that is
really interesting i like that i like
that oh i had this weird idea that just
popped to my mind while you were talking
that like what if what so they just
character called sleepwalker in the
marvel comics that i feel like is so
underrated
and like what if there's like a
sleepwalker department of like people
that are just
specifically for helping nightmares it's
like we're the sleepwalkers we're going
around and we're
we're fighting all these people um so i
i that's what i would do if i was if i
if they were if marvel had no plans with
sleepwalker property
so like yeah what if i think that there
was like probably a different branch of
um
agents that are called something else
that probably work in conjunction
with the time keepers for some
particular reason or maybe just like a
a different place all together on a in
the null time zone which is like all
right
time time variance authorities over here
and now we're the i don't know
sleepwalker guys
uh i think we have time for one more
question what's our last question
our last question of the day is wait a
damn minute with the term nexus event
could that be another connection with
wanda maximoff who was defined as a
nexus being in juan division yeah so
remember episode 7 had that
nexus antidepressant commercial and
later we found out from the people
writing the show that they wanted all
those commercials
to be messages from dr strange uh they
ended up
cutting that doctor strange cameo
because they wanted the final episodes
to be more about wanda's grief and her
overcoming that grief and
and defeating agatha as someone who is
trying to manipulate that grief
um but uh yeah this idea of nexus
is still an important word because it
was deliberately chosen as a reference
to the fact that wanda maximoff in the
comics is a nexus being it's someone
who's kind of
detached from reality but is kind of
this fulcrum character
in a way that uh that can transcend
reality and and uh change the fabric of
reality around them
certain characters are so powerful
that's what they are um
and wanda maximoff is one of them uh and
i have to imagine that
by labeling these things nexus events
that that's an intentional connection to
these things
when a character is powerful enough and
uh cogent enough
to take an infinity stone or however
they breach
the sacred timeline uh that is a nexus
event and if they
are good enough at this and they do it
uh over and over and over they start to
just get further and further removed
from the sacred timeline
uh don't even remember what their origin
timeline was and they can evolve into a
full nexus being
wanda maximoff i think is just so
powerful already as a scarlet witch that
she can bypass that process
but the result is the same that you're
someone who now kind of exists in a
separate reality
and it's so powerful that you could just
change the nature of reality around you
not just the town of westview but an
entire universe that that's within
dang bro like that that would be a great
way to to connect with wanavision with
with
loki and this would make sense because
the head writer for loki mike waldron
and jack schaefer
worked pretty closely together um during
you know the the productions of one
division
and loki um so i think that they
probably coordinated and obviously
with with the mcu being the mcu kevin
feig is probably like put nexus
put the word nexus everywhere all right
we call it a nexus event
yeah call it next event don't even worry
about it um
so you know yeah and you remember though
the wording of that commercial was like
uh next is antidepressants they'll
ground you in reality or a reality of
your choosing
i think it's all kind of signaling the
same thing that reality is not something
that's
that's fixed it it's something that can
be tinkered with it can be split off
into a new reality and that's just what
the multiverse is
i think as you pointed out before we
heard multiverse and madness in pretty
much the same sentence
i think this show is very much headed to
dr strange's multiverse of madness
and i think that's that's what we're
gonna see i i wouldn't be surprised if
loki even showed up in it
or some element from the show maybe with
the sacred timeline
unraveling and splitting and shattering
into a bunch of uh realities in a
multiverse
could be the predicate for doctor
strange's crisis
for sure and we'll leave it there for
now because uh we want to jump on this
easter egg breakdown that should come
out later today
um but that is it for this episode of
inside marvel
uh yeah the next video on the channel is
gonna be the straight breakdown stay
tuned
there's a bunch of little details they
filled this show
together
mt and i are gonna be back next week to
react to episode two and we have a lot
of videos between now and then
explaining the other big questions going
deeper into stuff we talked about in
this video
uh finding new revelations to uh break
down for you guys
now remember uh you gotta check out our
great
loki loki out of time
uh that wall clock uh everything the
stickers
uh you can share uh mt's wife
with him you know what i will share my
wife with the world i'm into that
so she's an animated character and she
belongs to no one
uh she belongs to the streets eric the
internet maybe she belongs to the
walt disney corporation
[Laughter]
well uh follow mt at mastertainment
follow me at ea voss follow new
rockstars of course subscribe to inside
marvel wherever you get your podcast
and subscribe to rockstars on youtube
hopefully we're at 3 million subscribers
i hope so
let's get i'm so excited thank you guys
yeah thank you guys so much that is very
exciting
uh we'll close this week with our
favorite moment from the episode
i was just standing up to make a point
i'm sorry go ahead my baby is meaningful
now
okay we'll stay seated i'll do what i
want to do
[Music]
you